since the outbreak of the corona virus
pandemic the EU has taken a lead role in
coordinating the response here are the
top 10 things that yiyu is doing to
fight co vid 19 slowing transmission
unprecedented challenges called for
unprecedented measures by closing
external and Schengen borders to
non-essential travel the EU has helped
to limit the spread of the virus both
within Europe and beyond providing
equipment the EU is supporting national
health systems by providing access to
stockpiles of supplies EU countries have
pulled their buying power making joint
purchases of equipment over 3 billion
euros of EU aid has been mobilized to
buy tests and help medical staff care
for patients boosting research the e use
horizon 2020 program is supporting 18
projects and 151 research teams to find
a vaccine and better understand kovat 19
improving diagnosis clinical management
and treatment European solidarity
parliament has backed new rules allowing
the EU solidarity fund to cover health
emergencies up to 800 million euros will
be made available for member states this
year assuring the recovery to help the
EU bounce back from the economic and
social impact of the pandemic the
Commission will now propose a stimulus
package as part of the next long-term
budget MEP s want to see a massive
recovery and reconstruction package
supporting the economy the EU is
offering a five hundred and forty
billion euro package to support workers
businesses and Member States the ECB is
providing 750 billion euros to relieve
government debt on top of this MEP s
have already approved a 37 billion euro
package to support healthcare businesses
and workers protecting jobs to ensure
workers can keep their jobs if companies
run into trouble the Commission is
proposing new measures to allow
subsidized short time work the EU has
unlocked 1 billion euros in loan
guarantees allowing banks to support
some 100
and businesses repatriating citizens the
EU Civil Protection mechanism has helped
tens of thousands of Europeans stranded
around the world to return home helping
developing nations the EU has released
20 billion euros to help poorer
countries as part of the coordinated
global fight against kovat 19 ensuring
accurate information disinformation is a
major threat to public health Parliament
is calling for a new European
information source to ensure all the you
citizens have access to verified factual
content it's also our social media
companies to tackle fake news and hate
speech
[Music]
you